[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle grille de lecture avec
aujourd'hui une sélection de polar
bonjour stéphanie bonjour isabelle et
bon vent laurent josée mon prêt à la
laiterie du pavé du canal bon alors on
commence tout de suite parce que oui on
sélection assez riche avec je m'appelle
baradji voilà oui de front commun nara
qui était en premier roman cette hauteur
là qui est un musicien est à la base un
milicien quoi de rock well de rock and
roll à sunderland
et donc c'est une traversée une descente
aux enfers dans la vie parisienne
donc c'est un roman très très trash donc
l'histoire d'un guitariste qui devient
détective privé qui va suivre une jeune
bourgeoise danser i'm a foncé dans les
bas-fonds des mastrad pilule bleue lacs
sont attribués qui fait des morts par
par centaines voilà donc et donc essayer
de comprendre pourquoi cette drogue est
distribué à qu'ils allaient distribuer
en tous les cas dans tous les réseaux
et puis un petit côté aussi politique
sur les mouvement néofasciste d'accord
voilà parisien comment ça s'articule est
vraiment c'est intéressant fin vraiment
c'est compliqué à lire parce que c'est
quand même très très trash donc il ya
des scènes de sexe consentie ou non sont
des sexes oui voilà des scènes de drogue
d'overdose voilà donc un nu détails mais
vraiment c'est passionnant fin on est on
est happé par cette histoire et on suit
donc cette enquête qui est l'italien
franco non c'est un français ouais on
sent que c'est un vrai musicologue quoi
enfin voilà parce que ce détective privé
à une vraie
la scion vraie passion enfin il est
guitariste et joue dans un groupe et
donc il sort plein de disques enfin
voilà il ya toute une
tout un pan de l'histoire du rock
français qui est déclinée qu'est
vraiment aujourd'hui ça se passe au
voyage de nos jours très encore voilà
passion mais pas à mettre dans toutes
les mains parce que stéphanie vous
l'avez les noms n'ont pas du tout accord
c'est pas eu tout ce que d'accord c'est
le breaking bad
un peu ça c'est donc voila merci merci
beaucoup
pauline est ce que c'est vous qui allez
nous parler de je vous laisse dire son
nom
moi c'est stéphane dit stéphanie pardon
excusez moi alors j'ai besoin qu'on
prononce choucha longue chevauchée voix
labeaume n'a cru si on dit que fiat on
arrête on voudrait rire on comprendra
une libraire comprend qu'il est d'entrer
en tant qu'etat d'auteurs chinois
originaire de shanghai qui a eu une
bourse pour aller faire ses études aux
états unis et qui suite aux événements
de tiananmen a choisi de rester aux
était restée là-bas
voilà donc aujourd'hui il vit aux états
unis il enseigne d'ailleurs aussi aux
états unis d'accord en revanche ses
romans se passe toujours un chandail ray
il porte un regard donc sur la société
et d'aujourd'hui cirque il ose écrire et
décrire une société chinoise aujourd'hui
corrompu où l'argent est très très
présent où le parti est omniprésent où
la corruption est aussi très présent ça
c'est quand même car oui tout à fait
plutôt dure d'ailleurs
par contre ce que j'adore c'est qu'on
est vraiment dans shanghai
on est dans un shanghai paille ou
touristiques on aimerait un shanghai qui
a priori meurent aussi un petit peu à la
chine aimant plus qui est passé mais
prévoit là après les préfère ce qui est
de l'avenir donc tous les petits
quartiers au contraire lui il en parle
beaucoup son inspecteur c'est
l'inspecteur chen construit de l'image
et du genre le mec il est nommé chen cao
voilà j'aime chaos qui avec et poète à
ses heures est un fin gourmet même si on
n'aime pas du tout le cas
du malheur ils mangent beaucoup et même
si on n'aime pas effectivement la
cuisine c'est de la sorte de cuisine
chez les auteurs japonaise tout à fait
oui c'est vrai oui tout à fait c'est
très présent très présent dressé et
voilà ils ont emmené dans un shanghai
entre vie quotidienne vie politique
l'actualité voilà les gens qu'elles sont
toujours très bien mené très fine
alors qu'à l'origine abbas canada plus
récent celui qui est sorti en poche
c'est plus récemment c'est vraiment un
tigre blanc le premier je vous ai amené
enfin celui je vous ai amené c'est le
premier de la série en fait mort d'une
héroïne rouge
voilà c'est un auteur à découvrir pour
ceux qui connaissent pas et quand on ne
connaît effectivement on est on est dès
que ça sort on a envie de savoir
effectivement nos inspecteurs ce qu'il
devient la suite - nouvelle aventure
tout à fait et c'est vraiment très
chouette c'est vraiment très bien fait
et on passe un très bon moment de
lecture
encore merci vocaux stéphanie tu m'en
allais ont continué ce que c'est laurent
qui cessa ragdoll de daniel cole qui est
aussi un premier roman cette fois ci sur
un serial killer
mais alors le sujet quand même assez
lourds cette fois ci aussi donc c'est
ont retrouvé un corps qui a été
rassemblée par six victimes différentes
parties des deux parties de corps de six
victimes différentes web et donc on va
suivre en quête de cet inspecteur en
faite le
meurtrier va envoyer une seconde lettre
à la presse en disant qu'il va y avoir
six autres victimes
et donc ça va être tout ce cheminement
là dedans quête qu'on va suivre les
victimes si j'ai bien compris elles sont
mises en lumière par les médias on les
suit on les voit c'est ça oui voilà et
ça c'était du coup c'est assez troublant
oui c'est pire oui mais c'est vraiment
elle tant que vraiment c'est et alors
c'est parce sanguinolent s'appelle c'est
pas aussi sanguinolent qu'un château
mont utilise donc malgré le fait que sa
découpe un peu voilà ça reste sanaa tard
anglais c'est un auteur anglais
quand j'ai vu qu'il était bizarrement ni
qui donc assassines et tuent dans ses
romans sont des
dans la vraie vie je crois qu'il est une
simple qui fait partie de l'association
de sauvetage en mer de choses comme ça
donc c'est rigolo niveau du personnage
entre mollahs de l'auteur c'est à l'air
d'être une personne assez intrigante
intéressant moi ils sont carrelés aussi
quoi vraiment c'est passionnant quoi on
va jusqu'au bout ok mais ça se passe à
londres
et ça se passe à nous tous d'accord on
merci stéphane ils avaient libre non
plus bon allez on continue donc avec
deux livres encore une fois de
thomascook thomascook oui c'est toi qui
est un auteur américain
un peu comme crucial en fait c'était
pour un peu faire connaître voilà pour
ceux qui connaissaient pas ces deux
autres lots d'un flux récents que
l'autre un sens oui alors le style de
vie bon voilà et alors que le crime de
viol il est sorti l'année dernière ou
gentiment et des sûretés d'accord même
temps effectivement c'est un auteur
américain plus intimiste effectivement
que je suis sa longue
moi j'aime bien parce qu'il ya la
famille est très présente les secrets de
famille sont aussi très présents la
culpabilité et la rédemption sont des
thèmes qui ont été mises en valeur sur
les non-dits
voilà avec une ambiance mosphere aussi
un peu huit clos on n'a que quelques
personnages avec une psychologie très
très fine
alors ça frôle un peu le roman noir
parfois ce n'est pas forcément une
enquête classique n ya pas dû d'ailleurs
d'enquêteurs on est vraiment dans un
univers un peu huit clos un peu
troublant et qui est vraiment assez fort
au lieu dit du noir est en moi c'est
pour moi que c'était un livre qui
m'avait vraiment bouleversée que j'avais
trouvé très très fort c'est la voilà
celui là on a même un peu l'impression
c'est comme un long plan séquence comme
au cinéma où ça ce n'est pas grave c'est
voilà une comme si c'était une seule
scène elle se prolonge et dans le temps
et dans l'espace
et voilà c'était genre de l'eau manque
normand concours et qu'on apprend qu on
lèche le contraire oui confirme plus
pisser vraiment au dernier moment où on
se dit ah mais c'est ça la clé entre
guillemets on l'a vraiment qu'au dernier
moment et en plus on ne s'y attend pas
enfin c'est vraiment une chute qui en
général est assez aucun des lenteurs de
famille que pas toujours notamment sur
la sphère julien noël ça c'est pas une
histoire de famille même s'il y a quand
même
il revient aussi sur la sur celui là il
revient sur les événements qui s'est
passé en argentine là
pendant la dictature voilà ils
s'emparent de l'évènement comme ça mais
ce que j'aime bien c'est ce côté un peu
intimiste la psychologie psychologique
qu'on n'a pas forcément dans d'autres
polar d'alors donc c est le rythme était
aussi très agréable parce que comme
voilà comme il est fin psychologue
on s'arrête souvent longtemps sur un
personnage voilà à raconter son histoire
voilà pour comprendre ce qu'il se passe
et ce qui s'est passé d'accord très bien
du bon polar
merci ou de l'emv les avais cela non
mais j'ai bien envie vous allez à mon
ancienne avec le dernier ouvrage à cette
émission qui s'appelle la daronne alors
qu'est-ce qui nous en passer moi c'est
vraiment génial fn et c'est vrai oui non
c'est vraiment excellent c'est vraiment
très très bon c'est l'histoire d'une
jeune veuve de 53 ans qui en fait elle
fait des des traductions pour elle est
bilingue arabe et elle fait des
traductions pour la justice et elle
travaille notamment pour la brigade des
stups ont clairement le monde des
interprètes c'est vraiment le monde et
interprète
et puis le monde aussi la brigade des
stups parce qu'en fait elle a toujours
du coup un coup d'avancé sur sa liste
parce qu'elle traduit alors elle nous
raconte aussi pourquoi justement elle
est venue à ce métier là pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle parle arabe ou rameau elle a eu
une enfance et une adolescence et des
parents effectivement un peu un peu hors
normes on vénère
voilà et du coup pas mais elle a
toujours un coup d'avancé pour une
histoire de circonstance voilà elle va
finalement intercepté un go-fast piqué
donc la marchandise et l'a caché dans sa
cave et puis coulé petit à petit ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle a
dans quelques classes on retrouve un
petit peu du breaking bad quelque part
du midi je bosse il dit me drai avec
l'infirmière l'acquis ouais mais oui
c'est s'aider des gens normaux entre
guillemets ouais enfin en tout cas des
gens donc l'un des bons côtés qui passe
du mauvais oui parce qu elle le fait de
façon commenté je suis ray au net parce
que voilà est là elle a deux filles à
qui elle voudrait essayer de léguer
quelque chose de solide
elle a une maman qui est dans un ehpad
et qui coûte une fortune
on a tous des parents ou des vieux
parents fin ou détente voilà on sait que
ça coûte cher quoi enfin voilà oui
l'étude de saison voilà
voilà donc là c'est pour acheter des
appartements fin mai à cox était en
voyage
une bonne excuse moi mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'elle n'a jamais frôler
comme ça aussi pleinement avec dans
l'illégalité c'est seulement en face à
lille voilà quelque chose de déclencheur
puis on y va et puis bientôt un peu
sonné rigolo c'est que cet auteur est
elle-même à les avocats voilà elle est
avocate
c'est aussi et c'est elle sur l'info sur
la photo sur la couverture l ex les
retient dialogue et c'est la couverture
aussi et voilà
et puis lorsqu'il a surtout fait moi
c'est ça aussi qui m'a plu c'est bon le
sujet effectivement mais le style et le
ton aussi parce que c'est c'est drôle en
fait elle est parce qu elle est ce son
héroïne elle est très attachant bien sûr
et elle est drôle et les coûts sera si
fin voilà c'est ça aussi on s'amuse
cachée dans la cale non c'est puis le
rythme surtout c'est très endiablé c'est
le il n'ya pas de temps mort c'est très
très bien ficelé c'est très bien fait et
puis elle est très original quoi elle
est vraiment rigolote com com voilà l
affaire que d'ailleurs je crois avec cm
qu'elle a analysé
j'avais entendu ça et je sais pas il
faut l'entendre il faut l'écouter
effectivement salage et oui elle un
personnage à la voix d'ailleurs c'est
assez reconnaissable je trouve et c'est
vrai personnage je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui en tant qu'avocat elle
doit effectivement voilà on devra passer
inaperçu va se rendre à la wii non tout
à fait donc un bon moment un présent à
travers la et donc du coup la semaine
dernière voilà la semaine dernière où il
ya il ya dix jours enfin je me souviens
plus très bien qui il a eu donc le prix
polar anciens secrétaires nouvelle
récompense enfin merci beaucoup sk une
petite minute petites choses
supplémentaires que vous pensiez pas
avoir le temps de présenter les rouge et
bleu noué les noirs hommes qui est sur
le fil les rouges et les noirs les
rouges et les noirs d'un moteur italien
ouais un petit clin d'oeil sur pour une
fois on est du côté fasciste donc les
rouges les communistes les noirs les
fascistes et sur les années plomb de
l'italie et
et là pour une fois donc on est du
mauvais côté de la barrière et on se
rend compte que finalement les fascistes
ont si ce sont aussi des hommes avec des
vertus un honneur et c'est une vraie
enquête une enquête sur un tir non ces
roms principalement vers un étudiant
romain fasciste qui qui tient la fac et
et vraiment c'est une superbe enquête
aussi policière d'accord merci beaucoup
merci laurent mercier stéphanie pour
cette semaine de polars et à très
bientôt pour une nouvelle mission dans
les lectures
[Musique]